there are scenes of commemoration here
in this Capital City today
yes it's a
it's our own year of
all they didn't want but they fought so
hard to resist and huge sacrifices have
been made by this entire country
Ukraine's military officials and
politicians don't give officially the
numbers of the war dead but they are
significant Western officials have said
that Ukraine is thought to have lost
around a hundred thousand of its
Personnel either killed or injured
fighting on the front line and the names
of the Dead are commemorated and that
will be in everybody's thoughts today as
they mark this moment
yeah let's just listen in to the
ceremony that is taking place
[Music]
congratulations thank you for your
service you're our hero
please okay we'll do everything
[Music]
the award is accepted by his wife
and his daughter Carolina
ah
[Music]
um
please accept our gratitude and our
condolences what can I say we will never
forget what your husband has done for
the country look after yourselves Take
Care thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you very much thank you
I serve Ukrainian people thank you
Alexander
[Music]
kernel of police
his award is accepted by his wife and
his daughters
[Music]
please accept these words
from Ukrainian people we're grateful to
your husband
and we will never forget the heroity and
heroic actions of your husband
you look after yourselves
a golden star award is awarded to
kosherves
senior sergeant of civil Protection
Service
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you for your service I serve
Ukrainian people thank you foreign
civil Protection Service posthumously
the award is accepted by his mother
my condolences and please accept our
gratitude please hold on we will never
forget anyone
[Music]
I agree presidential decree
heroic actions
and protection of the Ukrainian
sovereignty and integrity during the war
time foreign
with the
Awards
[Music]
director of the communal Enterprise
use Sports School in cave region
thank you for your work
s
[Music]
of the third level is awarded
volunteer to a volunteer
thank you